Is The Nightmare Before Christmas a Halloween
movie or a Christmas movie?
Sure, viewers of all ages can indulge in the
stylish animated film for months on end and
still be in season, but no matter when you
watch, there are probably some things you
notice in the holiday classic as an adult.
It's no secret that Nightmare Before Christmas
writer and producer Tim Burton is a huge fan
of classic monster films.
Early in his career, he directed the animated
short Vincent, in which a young boy dreams
of becoming like his idol, the beloved classic
horror master Vincent Price.
"He doesn't mind living with his sister, dog,
and cats.
Though he'd rather share a home with spiders,
roots, and bats."
Shortly after, Burton directed the short Frankenweenie,
which would be expanded to a full-length animated
feature in 2012.
In both versions, a boy named Victor Frankenstein
resurrects his beloved pet dog.
This love of monsters of movies past comes
through loud and clear in Halloween Town,
where The Nightmare Before Christmas takes
place.
The entire populace is monstrous in appearance,
and adults will notice that they're frequently
references to specific literary and film monsters.
Dr. Finkelstein, the mad scientist who created
Sally and helps Jack conjure up a skeleton
sled team, very obviously draws on Burton's
love Dr. Victor Frankenstein.
Just about every monster in town is a reference
to a classic: Igor, the Wolfman, Mr. Hyde,
the Undersea Gal, Mummy Boy, the Vampires.
You name a classic, and you'll find them living
in Halloween Town.
There aren't a whole lot of kids movies about
having a midlife crisis, but The Nightmare
Before Christmas is an exception.
Jack's been the Pumpkin King for far too long
and sees himself stuck in a rut.
He feels bored with his life, so he haphazardly
throws himself into a new obsession.
He assumes responsibilities that no one has
asked him to take on and makes a mess that
basically spans the entire world.
For the most part, kids aren't at risk of
reaching a point where they feel completely
stagnant in their lives.
The theme of facing an existential void and
dealing with it in destructive ways probably
isn't too accessible to kids, though they
can probably appreciate that Jack is seeking
adventure in some way.
For adults, it's far easier to notice the
real-life emotions at the heart of Jack's
misguided actions.
Throughout The Nightmare Before Christmas,
viewers witness a mostly one-sided romance
in which Sally, in an endless effort to prove
herself to Jack, is continually subjected
to his oblivious nature and one-track mind.
Obviously, children recognize a romance budding
here, but it takes an experienced heart to
notice that Sally's giving way more than she
should for a guy who's so wrapped up in his
own existential problems.
Sally's sweet nature and desire to do good
are admirable traits to have, but for most
of the movie, they're wasted on a pretty selfish
guy.
Sally struggles with feeling acceptance and
joy in her life in Halloween Town in much
the same way Jack does, but her solution is
to try to make connections and help people
instead of wandering off and leaving her responsibilities
behind.
"I'm restless!
I can't help it!"
"It's a phase, my dear.
It'll pass."
Because this is a children's movie, Jack and
Sally get together in the end, and it appears
as though Jack has begun to understand how
his actions have consequences.
We hope.
Until he discovers Thanksgiving town or something.
Granted, Sally's obsession with someone she
barely seems to know leads to her creeping
around tombstones to get a look at him, poisoning
her boss, falling asleep outside his house,
and throwing herself out of windows…but
that's another problem entirely.
One of the most adult-oriented gags in The
Nightmare Before Christmas is the character
of the Mayor, a squat, two-faced humanoid
who's entirely uncertain of how to proceed
with just about anything in Halloween Town
without assurance from his constituents.
Most kids won't pay close enough attention
to politics to understand what makes the idea
of an incompetent mayor quite so funny, and
a little bit scary.
The Mayor's smiling public face contrasts
with the horror-stricken one on the other
side of his head, a conceit that tells the
viewer he's performing for the public when
he really has a host of fears about how the
town is run and his responsibility to keep
it running in an efficient manner.
When the Mayor approaches Jack's home with
plans for the following year's Halloween celebration
and Jack doesn't answer, the Mayor loses his
cool.
"Jack, please!
I'm only an elected official here, I can't
make decisions by myself!"
Politics and hideous monsters have never gone
together so well.
Except in real life.
Much like politics, most child viewers probably
don't have much first-hand experience with
casinos.
This is, of course, Oogie Boogie's entire
focus, surrounding himself with slot machines,
roulette wheels, and killer cards.
When Oogie rolls the dice and announces "Snake
eyes!" it's probably safe to say that the
kids watching only really get value out of
the snake that actually emerges from the dice,
and not what that roll means from a gambling
perspective.
Nor would they gain much insight when Oogie
bangs on the table to reset the dice to read
eleven, a much more desirable roll in this
context.
But why a miniature gambling world in the
middle of a place that's focused entirely
on monsters and Halloween mayhem?
What's the connection?
The scenes in Oogie Boogie's lair are some
of the most fun, but it's interesting to notice
that in this town where the dreams of childhood
Halloween reign supreme, the most feared monster
lives in a grown-up world with high stakes
that serve only himself.
When Jack falls into Christmas Town and leaves
overwhelmed by his excitement in this new
place, he gets the wild idea that he should
try to make Christmas his own.
Without understanding the first thing about
this strange new land, he attempts to engage
in research, but without ever asking any inhabitants
of Christmas Town for their own input or advice.
He just takes an entire holiday, no questions
asked.
"This year, Christmas will be ours!"
Of course, this arrogant need to just appropriate
whatever he wants ends up in disaster, with
Jack being shot at as he attempts to spread
Christmas cheer throughout the land.
It's only then, after he's almost blown apart,
that he finally realizes he's in way over
his head, and he actually decides to ask Santa,
who he kidnapped earlier, what the heck Christmas
is even about.
Santa, the person who's actually immersed
in the traditions of Christmas Town, decides
to share those traditions with Jack.
It's a much more genuine interaction that
Jack's attempts to straight-up steal the holiday,
and it introduces the good practice of seeking
out the advice of those with firsthand knowledge
on a subject, rather than blundering your
way through something blindly.
Kids might not see that message outright,
but adults will notice, and hopefully the
nuance sticks with younger viewers as they
grow older.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.